hey guys and welcome to another 1hour
flipping challenge uh today I'm going to
be focusing on some of the cheapest
items in RuneScape so all of these are
going to be very uh price oriented
towards the poorest of the folk in
RuneScape uh so I'm going to be starting
with only 10,000 coins and seeing how
much I can get in 1 hour so we're going
to be focusing on uh cheap items but
with really good return on our
investments so uh we're not going to get
a mill obviously in profit there's no
way that's happening but we might double
or triple our money which we never even
managed to do with a higher amount so
anyway let's get started 1 hour on the
clock let's go so since we obviously
don't have a lot of money I'm going to
be very specific which which item I buy
now I looked up the initiate CH on uh G
tracker and it seems like it does have a
good margin uh we're going to try buying
it for about the actively traded price
and uh we'll jump BM up a couple of GP
here and that's gonna be half our money
invested in just this item
uh but it looks like I could be able to
sell it for 15K maybe uh so it might be
a bit of a long shot but this item does
trade enough uh to maybe make this worth
it next up is the Bandos page 4 uh
trades enough uh we're going to see if
we can low ball it for maybe around $
2900 and we'll try going for
2901 and we can only afford one of these
at a time now it leaves us with 2400 GP
I'm not actually sure if there's
anything on this list that's that cheap
uh well white elegant skirt probably not
going to trade very much uh we have to
keep in mind that a lot of these items
uh while they have good margins and they
are cheap they do not trade very
frequently uh I had to look into the
leprechaun hat doesn't seem like it's
actually that cheap anymore uh what
about this Gad Gad gther Hammer H you
know what we'll give it a shot we don't
have a lot of other items to go for I
don't actually know what it is I've
never seen it before in my life uh but
for now let's put one in for
19999 and hopefully we can sell that off
now for the Bandos page 4 that already
came through that's awesome uh we'll try
selling it
for uh
5400 and that will be a nice profit
there cuz we're restricted pretty
heavily in the beginning but actually
getting our money doubled will really
help out uh it'll kind of be a little
bit of exponential gain whereas normally
it's not so much like that okay awesome
we have the Bandos page four coming in
for
5400 uh that's going to leave us enough
to buy two I believe no we don't uh
let's take out this GA Hammer I don't
actually think that's very likely we'll
go ahead and put an offer for two cuz
that'll be much more uh useful out say
5,800 and that leaves us with 2,000 uh
actually I did some ship math okay we
bought a pair of initiate Co I'm going
to say KO uh so now we're going to go
sell them off now it looked like we
could actually get a very nice margin on
that let's go have a quick look at the
item on G tracker once again yeah
they're all the way up to about 13,000
on G tracker uh so that's probably we
could sell them off for put them in for
13 let's just do 13k even who cares and
if those sell off that will be really
helpful because that will have pretty
much doubled our money okay we got
another Bandos page coming in for 2900
sell that off for 5400 once again I'm
going to have a quick look at the other
Bandos Pages uh because they are the
cheapest page and of all the items that
are ridiculously cheap like this uh
Bandos Pages do trade the most okay we
sold off another Bandos page 4 that's
awesome and now I'm going to put an
offer in for a Bandos uh page three as
well just to spread out everything and
looks like we could buy it for about
3K uh so we'll go for about that price
there 3,1 and I get actually for two of
those we'll go for two since we don't
have a better item all right guys we
have the initiate item sold for 13k that
is so useful uh we ended up making
a 9 8 to 99k profit on that that is
really nice uh we also have the Bandos
page three coming in which we're going
to drop in for uh looks like actually up
to 7K uh we'll try dropping in for
$69.99 so we're getting some nice
returns there and we have another Bandos
page for coming through just came
through now and we're going to drop that
in for uh
5400 uh so we can only do five of each
of these pages so I think this is the
second or third Bandos page 4 we flipped
another two Bandos page 4S perfect and
we have a Bandos page three coming in
another one uh which we'll try selling
off as well for
$69.99 uh we'll wait till we sell one
before I invest a little more money
there and I think I might put one more
offer in for the initiate uh Quest I
wasn't thinking I was going to but since
I actually did end up buying and selling
in like 20 minutes I might go ahead and
try another okay so we have another
Bandos page 4 sold as well as a page
three sold I wonder if it's the same guy
bought it uh so we'll go ahead and put
another offering for the p agage 3es cuz
that is a very nice margin on that as
well uh looks like
4K pretty happy with that and uh we have
10K to go find another item so that
should be enough okay so we didn't
actually find an item yet but uh we do
have the initiate Quest coming through
for
4632 uh which we're going to drop in for
uh 13k probably going to go try buy
another one of those cuz I don't know
it's like huge margin and uh they seem
to be buying and selling reasonably
quickly he's buying anyway uh we have a
page three sold perfect and two more on
the way as well as a page four coming
through for 2900 and we're going to pop
that in for 5400 honestly I did want to
try to diversify from the Bandos pages
but I probably should just go flip all
of the different types of pages so we'll
go have a look at the other ones okay so
with the rest of our money I think I'm
going to try to invest into Rune claws
uh it looks like it just shot up all of
a sudden this last couple hours so we'll
try buying it for 12 we'll just put all
our money in and we'll try selling it
for maybe 27k cuz that would be quite
nice uh run claws nothing here is too
organized and we'll try buying for
12793 that's all our money and perfect
we got another Bandos page coming
through going to sell that off for $
66999 as well and that's another
initiate Quest coming through for
4,632 uh which we'll have to pop in for
13k uh looking pretty good I think we've
already d or tripled our money and we're
only 24 minutes in okay so we got the
last Bandos page coming through for 3K
uh which will'll pop in with the other
one and uh excitingly we do have the
Rune claws coming through uh we have
zero money left over which is kind of
funny probably not the best idea but uh
so we bought them for
12793 and uh well let's
see I think we could sell them for 27 30
let's try 32k
in for
32k and that is a extremely good margin
I not sure what the use of run claws are
but clearly it does have a use cuz
people are trading them uh but yeah
hopefully they will end this last hour
okay so we just cross the halfway mark
uh but some good news we sold off uh one
of the initiate items for 13k that's
awesome I don't think I'm going to buy
any more cuz it's fairly slow and we did
flip the entire buy limit for the Bandos
page 3s and we just have one more to
sell on the Bandos page fours uh so that
is bringing our cash up to 30k three
times our starting Cash Plus we have
quite a few items to sell uh so this is
working quite nicely okay next up I want
to try the Mind
Shield uh pretty highly traded item for
the margin we might be able to get looks
like it's close to 4K yeah we'll have to
do two of these I guess and uh we
hopefully can sell them off for uh
around 15K I take that back we'll go put
another one in okay so flip to M shield
for a 4K profit pretty nice actually uh
considering that these actually trade
quite a bit more frequently than the
other items in this category can see
here like about four every 20 30 minutes
or so so I should be able to flip these
three I think before the 20ish minutes
are up uh the rest of these items I
don't know probably Dro down the Run
claw a bit they've been in there for
quite a while put them down for
29k and we'll leave that and I think
it's just a slow selling item okay we
finally have the Rune claws sold that's
exciting uh 30k is pretty well what I
ended up selling them for and we bought
them for 12K that is a 17K profit pretty
well uh leaving us with 48k in the
inventory uh which we only have 16
minutes to do something with we'll have
to find something quick I'm going to try
the holy blessing for
28k don't have a lot of time but uh
that'll probably do it and then we'll
just leave these items in and hopefully
they will sell in the last 15 minutes or
so okay we have the Holy blessing coming
through for 28k and uh we were going to
pop it in for uh
34 roughly alth it say a little higher
but whatever
34k and uh yeah that's going to be it
everything's selling uh 10 minutes left
no more buy offers so let's hope we can
sell everything okay only 7 minutes left
and we sold off both the holy blessing
and the M Shield uh bring our cash total
up to 80k if this sells we'll be close
to
100K uh but yeah I don't know if we'll
be able to tenfold our money but
hopefully this will sell hey there we go
I just came back from doing the dishes
and uh our initiate qu sold for 13k uh
that's going to be it guys 2 minutes 40
seconds not enough to do much in so
we'll just turn up the timer okay so I
mean there's no surprise or anything
this is how much uh we made in 1 hour of
fliping from a 10,000 coin start so
obviously 80k uh isn't a lot per hour
but when you consider that now I mean
now I have 93k and I can go do uh more
expensive items get better margins it's
not uh about how much money I made but
more about the return on the investment
which was uh nine times our starting
cash amount so pretty happy with how
this went there's a lot of good cheap
items that you can get extremely good
margins on as I'm always surprised and
yeah hope you guys enjoyed the video and
I'll see you guys in the next one
[Music]